when he walks into the residence he's
not the president of the united states
he's he's dead
and he's still dad nearly four years
after leaving the white house behind
barack obama is opening up about the
women in his life in a new interview
with instyle magazine
and we're cueing up the ah track
because he's straight up gushes over his
daughters
sasha and malia and his wifey michelle
when it comes to his oldest daughter 22
year old malia
the proud dad says she is just buoyant
quote she's somebody who enjoys people
enjoys life and enjoys conversation
she's never bored which is a bad quality
that can take you
places as for 19 year old sasha the
former president says she's
quote completely confident about her own
take on the world
and is not cowed or intimidated and
never has been
by anybody's titles anybody's
credentials
adding if she thinks something's wrong
or right she will say so
when she was four five six years old
once she made a decision
she would dig in and couldn't be steered
off it
as for the former first lady barack says
that while people know she's an amazing
public speaker
what they don't know is that she slays
in the gym
especially when it comes to boxing quote
you don't want to get in the way when
she's working on a bag
including some kicks there's force there
yeah she's a force outside of the ring
too
during a recent interview with cbs
sunday morning the 44th prez of the u.s
joked we shouldn't expect him to join
president-elect
joe biden's team in the white house for
the sake of his marriage
there are probably some things i would
not be doing because michelle would
leave me yes she'd be like what
and in a separate chat with 60 minutes
the promised land author got candid
about how his political ambitions
affected his family especially his
relationship with michelle
who initially did not want him to run
for president
we've got two young kids michelle's
still working
and i ask myself in the book you know
how much of this is just megalomania
how much of this is vanity how much of
this is me trying to
prove something to myself and over time
she made a conclusion that i shouldn't
stand in the way
of this um she did she should not stand
in the way of your ambitions
to be president yeah and and and she did
so grudgingly
well we all know how his ambition to be
president turned out
with two terms in the white house the
fact that i ended up
winning didn't necessarily alleviate
her her frustration because the toll it
takes on families
is real the fact that she
put up with it and forgave me it's
was uh an
act of of grace that i
am grateful for uh and i'm not sure i
deserved it
but back to that in style article the
mag
also published an excerpt from barack's
recently published memoir where he talks
about another badass woman in his life
his late mother anne dunham quote
appalled by racism she would marry
outside her race not once but twice
and go on to lavish what seemed like an
inexhaustible love on her two brown
children
incensed by societal constraints put
upon women
she divorced both men when they proved
overbearing or disappointing carving out
a career of her own choosing
raising her kids according to her own
standards of decency
and pretty much doing whatever she damn
well pleased